Well, welcome to the last lecture in for
this quarter.
Today we will be completing our road
map. Specifically, we'll be starting by
wrapping up our discussion on model-free
reinforcement learning first, where
we're looking at policy optimization
methods, and then we'll discuss
model-based RL.
So, if you recall, basically what we're
saying last time is that we started
looking at policy optimization
approaches for model-free reinforcement
learning, whereby the main idea was to
basically build these and compute these
policy gradients,
which are basically the gradients of the
kind of ground truth reinforcement
learning objective that we're interested
in optimizing, which enabled us to
basically derive the number of
algorithms ranging from reinforce to
actor-critic algorithms.
And then
we basically
concluded with
kind of having to basically discuss some
more recent reinforcement learning
algorithms that relate with policy
optimization.
And if we kind of kind of take a step
back and and think about how kind of
state-of-the-art algorithms in machine
learning more broadly typically work,
they ultimately boil down learning to a
numerical optimization problem, right?
So, let's think back for example at our
classical regression problem, you know,
which is described as a supervised
learning problem, where we typically
formulate it as a
training error minimization problem,
which we can optimize sequentially
taking a data set of observation until
we converge to some
to some local optimum.
And this is fundamentally different from
what we've been doing so far in
reinforcement learning, because if we
think back at value-based methods, kind
of Q-learning being a prototypical
example, this is well, first of all,
fundamentally different because we're
not really optimizing an objective, but
we're doing fixed point iteration, uh
which can in principle include kind of
all of the transitions from an offline
data set, uh but uh from the perspective
of trying to mirror this same uh
formalism, this is not really optimizing
the ground truth reinforcement learning
optimization problem.
On the other hand, we saw how policy
optimization methods on one hand do
optimize for the ground truth
reinforcement learning objective, but we
only do basically one step of gradient
descent at a time, right? So, we saw
these how at least nominally these are
on-policy algorithms, where we have some
interactions with the environment, we
collect data, take one gradient step,
and repeat, right? So, this is really in
a way fundamentally different from just
positing this as a numerical
optimization problem and kind of
crunching the numbers until we converge,
if that makes sense.
So, we'll discuss two specific
algorithms, uh namely uh trust region
policy optimization, TRPO for short, and
proximal policy optimization or PPO for
short, uh which originally kind of um
were born by trying to replicate this
sort of formalism of positing an
optimization problem and crunching it
until convergence
uh for the purpose of reinforcement
learning.
Where the goal therefore will be to
define a kind of a surrogate problem and
have it such that we can take continuous
updates to our policy before potentially
grabbing new experience from our from
our environment.
And so, we saw how in in policy
optimization, um
kind of what we want to do uh kind of at
least value is to compute the policy
gradient, right? Which uh last Monday we
defined as being the expected value of
the grad log pies multiplied by some
quantity, which is a a metric of the
reward to go, right? We saw how how an
attractive um
kind of quantity to have here is the
advantage, A.
Now, kind of the first idea is that what
we would like to have is define this
surrogate optimization problem where
whereby if we were to take gradients of
this objective function which we define,
the gradients would themselves be the
policy gradient
which are interested in following. And
so kind of
a simple idea which is also how you
might have seen by playing with your
presets
is that when you want to introduce kind
of concretely implement these kind of
things and solve them through automatic
differentiation, since we're interested
at the end of the day in following this
object over here, kind of
pragmatic way of doing so is to define a
surrogate objective
which is a quantity that we don't
necessarily care too much about in
practice, but if we were to take the
gradient of this objective, we would
actually get the policy gradient, right?
So, in practice this is how we would
normally implement this through auto
differentiation methods. We would define
the surrogate objective and auto diff
will basically give us the gradient of
this object which is the policy gradient
and we can follow that.
An alternative
kind of representation of this surrogate
objective which we might want to use in
the exact same way
is what I'm referring here as the
um kind of loss
IS where IS stands for important
sampling
which is essentially an equivalent
objective to the one shown here above
whereby
rather than having this defined as the
log pi multiplied by the advantage, we
have this
probability density ratio which comes
from an old version of our policy pi
described by some old parameters theta
old and a potentially new version of
that same policy described by some
current parameters theta.
So, first of all, kind of to sanity
check that the gradient that we get from
these two is equivalent, just by
applying the chain rule, we will see
that the
well, the the grad of the logarithm of a
function is actually equal to the
gradient of this ratio.
So, the gradient gradient of the
function divided by the function
evaluated
at the at theta old.
And [snorts] so,
long story short is that these are kind
of two separate surrogate functions we
could use to nominally get the policy
gradient out of it in the same way.
However, the second one, that is the
important sampling one, has this nice
interpretation whereby this objective is
actually well-defined even if you are
using uh
kind of collecting data according to a
previous version of the policy. In this
case, theta
pi theta old.
So, you're probably starting to imagine
how this form this objective is still
valid in the moment where I'm updating
my policy kind of multiple steps
sequentially in a row. So, I'm kind of
diverging from my original theta old
policy.
And this objective is still valid in the
sense that the important sampling is
kind of re-weighting my
probability that I give to the action
with respect to my previous version of
the policy.
So, I I'm aware that I'm going through
this quite fast,
but the main idea is that
we want to
um
kind of reach the state where we are
defining a surrogate surrogate objective
which
still follows the main ideas of policy
gradient.
Here we're seeing two different
alternatives which are equivalent in
that sense because these are two loss
functions which if we differentiate
we'll still get the policy gradient.
Uh but this important sampling version
has this nice interpretation which still
holds when we are actually considering
data collected according to a previous
version of our same policy.
Does this make sense?
And so, of course, this uh uh
is So, this is the objective that kind
of is used within the uh trust region
policy optimization algorithm with a
caveat. And the caveat, which we didn't
discuss here, is that So, here we are
mentioning this this idea of
uh taking multiple steps and therefore
starting to diverge from our original
theta old.
Uh but of course, the more we go uh
further away, so the more we move from
our original theta old, the our
estimate, for example, of the advantage
will be uh less accurate.
Uh
and the more potentially this ratio will
kind of stagnate uh learning to some
extent, right? And so, what we want to
do is we want to potentially take
multiple steps sequentially, as we were
saying, uh but we want to do this while
remaining within uh kind of a
neighborhood uh
of the original policy,
within which we are kind of confident
that what we're doing is still
meaningful.
And so, this is the idea of introducing
what is uh often referred to as a trust
region. This is a uh pretty common
technique in optimization, whereby uh
given that same objective that we were
discussing before, we're now introducing
this constraint, which is basically
expressed expressed through the KL
divergence, that is a measure of
divergence between uh distributions,
such that we want that the distribution
of our action induced by our old policy,
theta old,
has to be closer uh with kind of delta
close uh
to the new policy, to the new
distribution of our action induced by
the new policy, by theta, to some
extent.
So, why is this interesting? It's
because of course, there could be many
possible ways of um
defining closeness for two policies.
Maybe one more intuitive way would be to
just measure distance in parameter
space.
Um for example, penalizing like the the
norm of the distance between the two
theta vectors. Uh but this is pretty
attractive because this is directly
evaluating distance in uh kind of policy
distribution space. Which is ultimately
what we care about. Right? So, we are
measuring distance with respect to the
distribution of actions induced by the
two policies. So, maybe the parameters
vary
quite a lot, but ultimately what we care
about is that the distribution induced
by the policies remains uh similar.
Yeah.
Mhm. Yeah, so this kind of depends also
um
if you're averaging over different
trajectories. So, remember that this
will be doing kind of an empirical
evaluation of this. Right? So, we'll be
sampling multiple trajectories over time
and kind of doing empirical means
instead of expectations. But this is
why. Yeah.
So, this was
um
incredibly successful at the time. Uh
meaning it it was able to, you know, be
a pretty reliable uh reinforcement
learning algorithm, especially for a
continuous control problems.
Uh however, it came with its own set of
limitations because of course uh now we
are changing we changing from having to
solve an unconstrained to actually
having a constraint in our formulation,
which complicates things.
Um specifically, uh in order to solve
these problems, uh people usually use
conjugate gradient methods, which can be
tricky to implement.
And empirically, uh this also see this
algorithm um
usually seemed uh to perform pretty
weakly when we're using maybe deep
neural networks such as convolutional
neural networks or large transformer
networks. Um which
was indeed one of the main kind of
practical limitations of TRPO.
So
uh
this algorithm was still extremely
impactful because in a way it motivated
kind of successive algorithms which try
to simplify and remove these
limitations, which is exactly what PPO
actually is. So PPO in a way is a
derivative of TRPO.
Uh which is trying fundamentally to
answer the question of can we replicate
the exact same objective that we were
trying to achieve with TRPO without
having to resort to this second order
optimization, which is basically
entailing this more complex optimization
problem that we have to solve in the
constrained problem that we introduced
in the previous slide.
Is the setting clear on kind of this
transition from TRPO to PPO?
Okay.
And so if you kind of
look around for different
implementations of PPO,
most likely you will stumble upon one of
these two versions. So the first one is
well, we have this constrained problem.
We are saying that this is introducing
some challenges at least from an
implementation perspective.
Let's basically move the constraint to
the objective function with a penalty
through Lagrange multipliers,
which then leads to an unconstrained
problem. And let's solve this through
stochastic gradient descent tools as we
have always done.
So in a way this is completely valid.
Although I would say that uh
most popular version is this second
version here
where uh we are basically trying to
empirically replicate the behavior of
the constraint
through um
kind of um an empirically derived
equation in a way. So, we're basically
introducing um
uh this specific objective here,
where we are trying to replicate the
behavior of this uh constraint, which we
introduced before.
How are we doing so? We're doing so by
first of all, defining the the ratio uh
just for compactness as uh a small r of
theta. So, this is the ratio between the
two uh policy distributions that we were
using before. Of course, if we evaluate
r at the old uh
um kind of version of the parameter
theta, we will get r equals to one.
And the objective is composed comprised
as the minimization between two terms.
The minimization here is used as such
that we are basically having uh
that this overall objective is a lower
bound of the ground truth objective of
the ratio times the advantage.
So, we're basically picking the minimum
between the ratio times the advantage
and this uh clip term over here.
So, what does the clip function do?
We're basically taking the
ratio, small r.
Assume this is the axis where we're
considering small r.
And we're basically saying that we are
constraining it to be between 1 -
epsilon and 1 + epsilon.
Right? So, if r falls within
these two bounds, we're keeping the uh
well, the value of r. Otherwise, we're
clipping it to So, if r theta would be
here, we would be using 1 - epsilon. If
r theta would be greater than 1 +
epsilon, we would be using 1 + epsilon.
So, we're basically keeping r theta in
between these values and then the
extremes when we're going beyond that
value.
Uh of course, this gets then multiplied
by the advantage. So, you're starting to
see how this is, at least intuitively,
an empirical way in which you can
somehow approximate this idea
uh whereby we want to stay closer to the
original policy, right? Because we are
constraining
we're basically
these values are constraining the ratio
r theta to be only uh
as kind of not incredibly different from
the original policy. Does that make
sense?
Yeah.
Yeah, so the point of the minimum here
is that
uh so the
full picture here is that we are
interested in the gradients that we get
from this objective. And specifically,
we want to saturate the gradients when
whenever we are kind of
beyond these clipped values, but only if
these are kind of in a negative
direction. Meaning, if we are moving
very far away from the policy, but we
are
moving in a direction that is negative
for performance, we want to clip it.
On the other hand, if we if taking a
bigger step would allow us to bring us
closer to the uh
um to the to the previous policy, we are
still enabling gradients to to flow. So,
this has this minimum uh I I kind of
advise you to maybe even just plot this
and trying to see kind of case-by-case
scenarios, but the overall intuition I
think is there are two. One, this is
allow allows us to have a
lower bound on the actual objective. And
two, if you look at the behavior of the
resulting gradients that you get from
this objective, you're getting something
that saturates whenever it it is
actually good to saturate. And it
doesn't when you want to recover,
essentially. Yeah.
But yeah, so long long story short, kind
of PPO uh of is derived from the same
intuitions that we are discussing before
from TRPO.
Uh and this is definitely the most
popular versions you will you will find
out there. And I would arguably say that
now PPO is probably one of the most, if
not the most, uh popular reinforcement
learning algorithm uh
out there.
Okay.
So, uh before uh moving to today's
lecture, uh first of all, any any
questions uh so far?
Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> So, just uh I want to spend just a
couple of minutes uh really kind of
driving home the main messages which we
discussed so far for model-free RL.
And so, remember how we basically
started all of our discussions a few
weeks back about talking about uh
different ways to estimate value
functions, where we were originally
motivated by the appealing properties of
dynamic programming,
uh where these were essentially allowing
us to
um
kind of
decompose the problem over time by
enabling us to have an exact
representation of the value uh for each
state at the end of our problem by just
looking at the one-step uh propagation.
And we were able to do this because we
are actually able to compute exactly
those expectations through the use of
the knowledge of the system dynamics.
And so, we saw how these methods were in
principle exact because this uh we were
not losing any information through this
uh one-step expectation. But, it
required us to have a knowledge of the
underlying MDP.
And so, this motivated to introduce kind
of two fundamental model-free learning
paradigms, uh Monte Carlo learning,
which basically uh
used sampling from our environment, uh
kind of in other words, interactions
with our environment to approximate that
expectation,
uh and specifically defined the update
to our value function as taking a step
in the direction of the observed
returns. So, we would sample in our
environments, reach a terminal state,
observe a return, and update our
estimate of the value function towards
that return.
On one hand, this is great because it's
unbiased. This is an actual unbiased
estimator of the ground truth return.
But, it is high variance because there
is a lot of stochastic sampling
happening over time. Uh and we need to
reach a terminal state in order to
actually sum backwards all of the
rewards that we have obtained.
On the other hand, temporal difference
learning tried to combine ideas from
both of these paradigms, the sampling of
Monte Carlo because we're still
interacting with the environment, and
the bootstrapping of dynamic programming
because we're updating our guess towards
the one-step ahead uh get estimate of
our uh future return.
Which is great because this lowers the
variance because we're sampling only
once in instead of having to account for
all the stochasticity of uh the possible
futures,
and it can learn online because we can
do this update with just a single step.
But, it does introduce bias because
we're updating the guess towards a
guess. And so, there are some some
tradeoffs.
Of course, we mentioned how this is true
both for state value functions V, but
also for Q functions, uh and this holds
uh equally.
Uh kind of the other main idea is that
we we saw how uh all of these ideas uh
basically uh held through for the
tabular representations, whereby value
functions are just a list or matrices,
and each uh entry in those lists of
matrices is our estimate for the value
function.
And it holds similarly for uh value
function approx- functional
approximation, whereby rather than
having lists or matrices, we have a
parametric function uh described by some
parameters theta, which we can uh
basically tune in order to a better
approximate these values.
How do we tune them?
Exactly how we were defining before
these
backups for the tabular case. Now, these
same targets, that is the return and the
TD target, represent elements in a
update for in parameter space.
With all of these machinery, we then
looked at value-based methods and policy
optimization methods as kind of two
broad families of model-free
reinforcement learning approaches.
In value-based methods, we used
generalized policy iteration as the
fundamental kind of scheme in order to
obtain
optimal policy.
In generalized policy iteration, loosely
speaking, alternates between two
processes. A
policy evaluation step, whereby given a
policy, we estimate the value for the
policy.
And a policy improvement step, which on
the other hand tries to be greedy with
respect to the newly update updated
value function.
And we saw kind of on-policy and
off-policy algorithms, namely SARSA and
Q-learning as specific examples, and how
these were instantiations of that same
framework.
Of course, this applies also when you
have deep neural nets in the picture.
And we looked looked at deep Q networks
as a specific example.
For policy optimization, which we just
concluded today,
we on the other hand said that
in policy optimization, we care about
learning an explicit parametric policy
theta pi theta with some parameters
theta, and we want to optimize these
parameters to kind of directly optimize
the reinforcement learning objective, as
we said today.
And this
at a very high level entails, well,
estimating the gradient if we want to
solve them through gradient descent
techniques. And so, all of our
discussions of policy gradient fall into
kind of step one here. And then we want
to do approximate gradient descent using
this gradient.
We saw how policy gradient naturally
describes this idea of trial and error
learning by essentially being
weighted version of the maximum
likelihood gradient. If you recall here,
we were describing this idea where the
policy gradient tries to basically push
up the probability assigned to actions
which have high reward.
And so this encodes this idea of trial
and error learning.
But we saw how policy gradient is
fundamentally doomed by this problem of
high variance of the gradient itself.
And so we discussed a number of
different strategies to reduce the
variance. Namely, we looked at baselines
and we introduced critics in
actor-critic methods
and and and so forth.
Okay, so if you wish this is like a
3-minute run through everything we've
been doing over the last few lectures,
but I think it's good to kind of
make sure that we are driving the main
ideas home. But any any questions on
this?
Okay, great.
So
um
So remember that basically
we were introducing this skeleton and
all of the methods we discussed so far
essentially
are different instantiation of this key
RL skeleton, right? So we always have
this generate samples step where we
interact with an environment.
We typically could estimate a return or
a value function of sort. So we could be
having a value function approximator,
for example. We'll see today how we
could fit the model as well.
Um and then we could use whatever we do
in the second step to improve the policy
either through
greedy policy improvement as we're doing
in Q-learning or through gradient
descent as we're doing in policy
optimization methods.
And at the beginning of our kind of
reinforcement learning lectures, we
briefly mentioned a number of trade-offs
between algorithms and ways to navigate
these algorithms.
But I hope that maybe before these
trade-offs were, I guess, a little bit
vague. But now if we actually look at
those same slides again, I hope that
most of these trade-offs start to make
sense. So we're discussing trade-offs in
terms of sample efficiency and
stability. And so I think here kind of
on-policy and off-policy algorithms are
exactly hinting at these trade-offs over
here. That is, how many how much is it
expensive for us to interact with the
environment?
We looked at continuous or discrete
action spaces,
which, you know, could have implications
in choosing value-based methods opposed
to policy optimization methods. We
looked at episodic or infinite horizon
cases where Monte Carlo requires an
episodic setting because we need a
terminal state to back propagate those
values.
And loosely speaking, I think we started
to
explore kind of these this spectrum of
sample efficiency, right? So we were
looking at
for example, ranging from the less
efficient algorithms. All the way here
we see kind of on-policy policy gradient
algorithms. We have actor-critic
algorithms, which try to leverage value
function approximation to become more
sample efficient.
We looked at off-policy Q-learning as
example where we could use offline data
or data gathered from other policies,
which makes it more sample efficient.
And today we'll be introducing
kind of some key ideas in the realm of
model-based RL.
But long story short is that, you know,
we had we introduced these trade-offs,
I guess, pretty vaguely at the first in
the first lecture. But but hopefully you
are appreciating how many of these
trade-offs now are more concrete.
Okay. And so let's move to model-based
approaches.
Specifically today we'll be
uh starting from well, introducing uh
basic recipe for model-based
reinforcement learning. Uh and we'll
discuss the key limitations and
challenges that come from this basic
recipe.
And then we'll start to see basically
different ways of uh addressing those
challenges and limitations, namely
through the lens of uncertainty
quantification. And so we'll have a
small parenthesis on uncertainty
quantification in in general.
And then we'll conclude with some
examples as well as some more broader
scope uh remarks for the entire class.
The caveat here is that of course
uh model-based RL is goes
uh clearly beyond anything that we'll be
discussing today.
But for today, I hope that at the very
least we'll be conveying kind of the
main ideas and challenges that come
through uh model-based reinforcement
learning.
Okay, so let's start from introducing
this general recipe.
So, at uh at the very kind of
fundamental level, if we knew the
dynamics, that is a function that
basically predicts the next state given
the state and an action that we take in
that state,
uh we could use tools from optimal
control, right? So, basically pick a
method from the first half of this class
we could use, right? We have a model, we
could plan through it, we could use a
direct method, indirect method,
uh basically uh our favorite choice.
And so, kind of a very simple idea would
be well, we want this object because it
could allow us to use any of the tools
we discussed before. Let's use
interactions with the environment to
collect data
and examples of these transitions, and
let's learn an approximate model of this
ground truth dynamics.
And so, we could apply a a strategy that
looks uh like the one shown here on the
slide, whereby we might have uh a base
policy
pi zero in this case. This could be
random. It could be
an exploration policy that is given to
us from some pre-knowledge or anything
that we choose.
And we could collect and we would run
this in the environment and use this to
collect data set of transitions, which
are basically comprised of these
triplets over here.
Right? So, we would be
running our policy in the environment.
In doing so, we would be seeing examples
of these one-step transitions.
Which we can then collect to basically
be examples of mapping from
uh
state and control to next state.
Once we have this data set, we can then
fit a dynamical model to this data
through our well-favorite regression or
supervised learning
technique. For example, minimizing some
form of squared error or maximizing some
log likelihood over our data.
And then we could use this model to
basically plan.
So, the question here is would this
work?
Well, in some cases, yes. Right? So,
especially if dynamics are relatively
simple. For example, we could have some
linear time invariant dynamics.
This tends to work pretty well.
And this also relates to some of the
discussions we were doing on
system identification. Whereby if we
have fairly well-understood model, if
the underlying dynamics are within the
function class that we're trying to fit,
and maybe we only have to tune limited
number of parameters,
then these tools actually work quite
well.
And we might hope to generalize good
enough to the to the real system.
Of course, this doesn't hold in
probably the majority of cases,
specifically when we're dealing with
complex, potentially non-linear
dynamics,
and especially in the combination of
complex dynamics and high-capacity
approximate models. For example, neural
networks.
And this is because extrapolating from
observed data to, for example, out of
distribution examples from our
environment is difficult and can be
misleading. So, for basically the rest
of this class, we'll be looking at
ways to basically
or approaches to try and
have this exact same formalism work in
the cases where
we might be having complex dynamics to
to learn.
Okay. So, why is this an issue? So, let
us look at like
fictitious and a kind of pictorial
example. So, say we are in this very
simple world, the agent is the black dot
here on the slide, and we have an
obstacle which we wish to
avoid. The goal here is to go as further
north as possible.
So, in this case, say that our
exploration policy pi zero is something
that explores a certain amount, certain
subset of the state space, specifically
describing the state distribution under
policy pi zero, P sub pi zero of X,
which is basically the subset of the
state space induced by that policy.
Of course, if we were to learn now a
dynamical model on this
transitions, which we collected through
this experience,
we might and then we use this for
planning, we might be ending doing
something extremely
meaningful within the the realm or the
states that we have observed, but the
moment where we change and we go outside
of the
state distribution we have covered,
this is obviously is the case.
And so, if you remember also our
discussions on
um imitation learning, this is another
example of kind of covariate shift and
distribution shift.
Whereby basically when we use the
learned dynamical model
as an inner component of our planning
algorithm, we're then observing a
different state distribution.
And so, here generalization and
extrapolation across these settings is
actually what matters.
Okay. So, what could be
a first
fairly heuristic and empirical way to
improve the the basic recipe we were
describing before?
So, again, let's consider our three
steps where we take a policy, run it in
the environment, collect some data,
use this data to fit a model, and then
say that we want to use this to plan.
Of course, what we could do first of all
is to plan in a receding horizon
fashion. So, we know that
the plan might be slightly off or at
least might be accurate closer to our
initial time, but then we might want to
reevaluate where we actually are in the
environment and replan. And so, in this
case, using a model predictive control
approach might be beneficial. Right? So,
this is a simple
a simple improvement here.
But also, what we could do is we could
basically use the transitions that we
are observing while deploying this
policy to basically add them to the
dataset and refit our model. So, in a
way, we are gradually closing the gap
between the state distribution induced
by the original policy and the state
distribution induced by this planning
policy. If that makes sense.
Okay. So, these are indeed two simple
steps which
can in practice make make a substantial
improvement.
However, kind of I would say the the
main focus for today is on uncertainty
quantification and we'll see we'll see
why shortly.
Specifically
the reason why
these techniques
fail is that in theory what we would
like to have is well, we have a very
complex dynamical model or system we're
interacting with and we would like to
have a high capacity model that is able
to come to represent these complex
dynamics in the high data regime. So we
want to have high capacity models.
However, we also want this high capacity
model to not overfit
to the observed data if we only have a
limited set of that data.
The reason why we don't want this
overfitting problem is because
if we then use
optimizer or a planning algorithm, for
example, as we were doing in our
previous recipe to optimize over a
learned model, we the optimization will
be prone to
exploiting errors in the positive
direction, if that makes sense.
So
visually
say that we have
only a limited number of data points
represented by the red dots here on the
slide.
Here we have two equivalent functions
that fit data. But the blue one here is
potentially representing
a higher capacity model that is
overfitting to the data, right? So it's
fitting perfectly our observed data,
but then it is doing this behaving quite
wildly outside of the observed data.
Now, say that you are an optimizer that
wants to maximize the performance from
the blue model, you might be tempted to
choose behavior that basically leads to
exploiting the positive reward
predictions under our model, right?
And so I think this is a kind of a key
problem here and a key tension when you
want to use learned models on one hand
that might not extrapolate or generalize
well with an optimization that is in a
way acting as a black box optimizer and
could exploit errors in the positive
direction.
So for
today, what we'll be looking at is a
possible solution to this problem, which
is basically considering
uncertainty and loosely speaking how
certain our model is about its
prediction as a mechanism to
basically push against these these
possible flaws.
Does that make sense? Any any questions
on on this?
Okay.
Okay, so first of all,
we're talking about uncertainty
estimation and what do we what do we
mean by uncertainty on the predictions
of our model?
And specifically, we mean
what we mean by uncertainty is we mean
an expression of a distribution
over possible outcomes.
So for example,
instead of predicting a single point
estimate of what is the most likely next
best state from given a state in a
control, we want our predict
system models to predict a full
distribution and associated likelihood
of what is most likely to happen in the
future, if that makes sense. So
visually, what we want from our
dynamical model is something that gives
us kind of a range of possible scenarios
that we could be optimizing for with the
associated
probability.
We want this because this essentially
allows us to reason in terms of
expectations under our model.
So, why is this
why can this really inform planning? So,
consider again this simple example where
we are the black dot on the side.
We want to reach a goal state
represented by the green star and we
have this kind of cliff-like environment
where kind of the the lines here
represents the edge of the cliff. So, if
we go beyond this uh
episode terminates essentially.
Now, say that we have two candidate
open-loop trajectories. So,
we basically assume we have access to
U1 to UT prime
and
U1 double prime
to UT
double prime.
And say we want to use something along
the lines of the model-based algorithms
we're using before.
We would basically be
kind of simulating in our heads these
two possible action trajectories,
open-loop trajectories, where one would
lead us kind of to
very close to the goal and one would
lead us a little bit more further away.
In this case, the circles represent kind
of our estimate of how certain we are
about where we would end up. In this
case, kind of both in both cases we are
fairly certain about where we're ending
up and so it's clear kind of that the
trajectory associated with the yellow
circle is is better because it then
allows us to be closer to the goal.
However, kind of
despite having in a second case assumed
that now we have broader uncertainty
bands around our terminal point despite
the terminal kind of the the best kind
of the expected value being the same in
both cases. Now we have a greater
uncertainty over those. And so the
expected reward under this higher
variance prediction would be lower for
the for the yellow circle, right?
Because under this new uncertainty
bound, we're actually considering the
case that in actually the majority of
the cases we're ending up ending up off
the cliff. Does that make sense?
So the reason why we care about
uncertainty estimation is because it
assuming we are able to do this, so
we're able to learn a model that gives
us an estimate of how certain we are
about our prediction, it gives us a
mechanism to express performance as
expected reward under our model.
Any questions here?
Cool.
Okay, so the next question is how can we
model uncertainty? We say we want to do
this.
What are different ways of doing so?
So the first idea is we could use the
output entropy from our given model.
So
I mean kind of pictorially what we are
trying to do is we are trying to learn a
parametric function which maps from
states and controls to probabilities
over next state.
In order to do this, we might be fitting
either kind of a depending on whether
the state space is discrete or
continuous, we might be fitting either a
categorical distribution over next
states. So we're assigning a probability
to each of our possible next states. Or
we might be fitting a continuous
distribution, say a Gaussian, which
basically expresses
you know, the the the mean value where
we expect to be and our standard
deviation and a variance of our
uncertainty.
In this case, of course, kind of the we
could use the entropy that basically
comes from the definition of the
distribution itself. For example, we
might be using the standard deviation of
the fitted Gaussian.
However,
a model entropy is different from
what is often referred in literature as
epistemic uncertainty. So, you might
have heard about this distinction
before, which is basically the
distinction between aleatoric
uncertainty, that is the
the noise that is intrinsically related
with the process that we are observing.
For example, here on the slide, we see
this kind of parabolic
process.
We have some observations of this
process
and there is some inherent noise that
might be observed from this process.
The other type of uncertainty is
epistemic uncertainty, whereby
we are actually uncertain about the
model itself.
Right? So, here we were certain about,
for example, the specific parameters of
this parabola.
It just there was some inherent noise
that is impossible to model.
On the other hand, again using this kind
of
fictitious example over here,
we might have two possible alternative
models, the green one and the blue one,
which with associated different
parameters,
which fit equally the model the observed
data, but are just two different models.
Right? So, here we would have two
different values of the parameters theta
that describe these two different
curves. And so, this is an uncertainty
between
on the model itself. So, which of these
two realizations of my parameters is
actually the one that
is better representing my my data?
So, using the entropy gets us somehow
some way along this path, but it clearly
does not
account for
what we actually care about, which is
the potentially mutually
coexistent and alternative explanations
of the data according to different
models.
Okay, so how do we model for this
how do we estimate for this model
uncertainty? I would say probably the
most
common approach for doing so is
leveraging
Bayesian statistics and Bayesian
approaches
whereby
typically what we are
interested in doing with Bayesian
approaches is that we want to
basically express this model uncertainty
as a distribution over parameter values
theta given the observed data.
Right? So, until now when we were
discussing
kind of fitting a model to our data, we
are often just saying that
we would be converging to a specific
value of our parameters theta.
On the other hand, if we are uncertain
about the model itself, we might be
interested in modeling maybe a full
distribution of how certain we are about
what the ground real value of the
parameters theta is.
And so, this is what we mean by
the distribution over parameters given
the the data set.
That is we are given some observation
and we want to ideally model the full
distribution of plausible hypotheses.
Why is this useful? It's because once we
have this full distribution,
uh we could actually predict through our
learned dynamical model
uh
by basically averaging out all the
possible future predictions that would
happen if we were to basically average
out over this full distribution.
And so this is referred to as uh the
predictive posterior distribution.
Formally, this is uh expressed through
this integral over here, where we're
basically saying that we're computing
the prediction of our next state
averaged over all possible values of my
uh parameters theta.
I think uh
you know, as as often the case, to
visualize these integrals is often
useful to see this in the discrete
setting. So, say we have only two values
of our parameters theta.
This integral, this predictive posterior
distribution, would essentially entail
uh running my predictions for both of my
values of theta, and then weighting the
prediction based on the probability of
each individual of theta.
This is the continuous kind of expansion
of that same idea.
How does this look in practice?
>> [snorts]
>> Uh well,
of course, uh we won't have time to
cover this here, but you know, Bayesian
statistics basically uh provides and the
Bayes' theorem provides basically a
mechanism to retrieve the posterior
distribution over parameters from from
data.
Um
but let's look at what the this means in
practice.
Uh for example, say we want to solve a
regression problem where we have some
uh well, we have uh
an X. So, we want to predict the value
of Y given X.
We want to fit here just a line to this
data. So, we have two parameters that we
want to fit.
Um so, the intercept and the slope.
Say that we have only one observation
from our ground truth process, which is
the dashed line over here.
Uh if we fit our model linear model to
this data, of course, there could be
many possible in principle infinite uh
lines that pass through the point.
Uh which in practice would mean we would
have a very a broad uncertainty over
possible values of our parameters
represented by this plot over here. So,
here we're plotting the two parameters,
say the intercept and the slope.
And so, we could see that while the
ground truth parameter is represented
here by the red
cross,
uh our posterior distribution is still
pretty broad.
What does this mean in practice is that
if you if we were to sample n
realizations of my posterior
distribution and plot the line,
you would get these different red
curves.
If we would then average out according
to the predictive posterior
distribution, we would get these
confidence bounds that we have on the
right.
Is the are are the plots clear?
Yeah.
And so, what we're showing here is the
basically progression as we collect more
data, right? So, here we're looking at
the case where we had only one data
point. Here we have more data points and
so, our posterior distribution of
parameters is more narrow and closer to
the ground truth. And you see how the
overall uncertainty bounds that come
from the posterior predictive are also
uh more uh concentrated.
Until here we are observing enough data
to have a pretty reliable estimate of
the ground truth model.
Okay. And so,
given that this is clear, let's briefly
mention a couple of I would say the most
popular approaches for modeling
dynamical systems
in a way that we are accounting for this
uncertainty. And we'll be looking at
two. The first one is Gaussian
processes, and the second one is
ensembles.
So, a Gaussian process, loosely
speaking, is basically represents a
distribution over functions.
Right? So, you could imagine that if we
are sampling from a prior distribution
over functions, that is before observing
any data, we will be getting pretty
different behavior.
On the other hand,
uh Gaussian processes basically
formalize
analytically a mechanism to go from a
prior distribution over functions to a
posterior distribution over function in
light of observed data.
Uh which would basically be still a
distribution over function that is
consistent with the with the data at
hand.
Um
kind of when I first approach also
Gaussian processes, I would say one of
the most confusing aspects to me was
this idea of distribution over functions
and what actually meant. In practice,
Gaussian processes
uh model data as multivariate Gaussians.
So, this is why they're referred as
Gaussian processes.
And
basically encode this idea that an
uh N-dimensional Gaussian, for example,
a two-dimensional Gaussian,
um
can be mapped so a sample from a
N-dimensional map
Gaussian can be mapped to basically an
approximation of a function.
So, say that we are sampling from this
two-dimensional Gaussian, say this point
over here,
which could be like five
and four.
Now, we could take this kind of
two-dimensional basically vector that we
just sampled. And if we plot it kind of
still in two dimensions,
what we could get is that we could get
a first value of five,
a second value of four.
And by connecting this, we're basically
getting
uh
uh discretization of a function now
described only in this small interval.
Now, of course, we can only plot things
in two dimensions, so maybe this might
not yet look like a function to you. But
now imagine that we're sampling an
n-dimensional vector from a multivariate
Gaussian.
Here we would get just a vector with
more numbers.
And if we still plot them in the same
way, we would basically get
the expression, you know, the
approximation of a of a function, right?
So, this is usually what
you know, how these are implemented in
practice and why people refer to the as
distribution over functions.
In practice, you can imagine that
Gaussian processes essentially provide
uh a mechanism to update from a prior
distribution
over functions to our posterior
distributions once we have observed
data.
Again, we're kind of sticking to
intuition, but uh I hope this is making
sense. Yeah.
Mhm.
Yes. So, here I was uh trying to provide
kind of an
intuitive uh understanding of what
people refer to as uh distribution over
functions. So, uh Gaussian process is
essentially representing uh
multivariate Gaussian distribution. So,
it's a
for example, here I was representing it
in two-dimensional.
So,
if we have this two-dimensional
Gaussian, a sample from it this
two-dimensional Gaussian could just be
this point over here.
Here I was imagining like 4 5 as
coordinates.
If we
uh would be wanted to plot this point as
a
function, essentially.
This would essentially be something like
this where we are basically
uh mapping this point and these
coordinates of this point but just
unfolding it into a function, if that
makes sense.
Now, the intuition is that
what happens if I want to build, you
know, like a full continuous function as
we were doing before, you could imagine
that it's basically a
more finely discretized version of this
with an n-dimensional vector, right? So,
if if rather than having two dimen-
two-dimensional Gaussians, I would have
an n-dimensional Gaussian, say a
hundred.
Uh then we would be able to basically
represent points on a very fine grid.
And by basically plotting these points,
you will get a function out.
Yeah.
>> Is it ready?
The values of the function.
Or is it like
like it Does it have to be the sequence
of numbers that the function would
output?
>> Uh yes, so maybe to rephrase what you're
saying, here we are implicitly assuming
an order of the of the dimensions. Yeah.
Uh but from the perspective of learning
this
the order doesn't change anything
because we're still fitting kind of the
the Gaussian that we are learning to a
high-dimensional object, right?
So, for us, kind of data will be living
in this high-dimensional space and we're
just fitting a n-dimensional Gaussian to
that data.
This is just the way we would then plot
it.
Yeah.
Okay, so why are Gaussian processes uh
popular?
First of all, a processes are extremely
data efficient.
Um [snorts]
and they provide an
an analytical expression for the exact
posterior. That is, the exact posterior
over functions described by your data.
Meaning,
given some data points and some
assumptions on Gaussianity,
we this distribution is actually the
exact representation of the posterior
distribution over functions that explain
this data.
This is
pretty cool, because if we wanted to
achieve something similar with neural
networks, this would be very hard,
especially with this amount of data.
Um
because this is a extremely low data
regime, and so getting these extremely
well-behaved
confidence bounds
is very challenging to have. On the
other hand,
Gaussian Gaussian processes achieve this
by having a an exact representation of
the posterior.
On the other hand,
I mentioned analytical expression of the
posterior. This analytical expression,
at least in the nominal case,
entails having to do some matrix
inversions. And so, depending which as a
function of n, where n is the number of
data sets of data points. And so,
scaling Gaussian processes to
high-dimensional data
is actually complex. And so, there are
extensions of Gaussian processes that
try to do so, but at least in their
kind of at face value, this is
definitely a weakness.
Okay, a second approach for estimating
uncertainty
is referred to as bootstrap ensembles.
And the idea is that
so, we have this general mechanism for
learning dynamical models through
supervised learning.
That is we just fit a black box model to
our data.
Uh, and we want to have an
encode an idea of uncertainty
on
in this estimation process.
So, what we can do is that let's The
idea of ensembles is let's train
multiple models
and see if they agree and where with the
underlying idea that these different
models will So, different models trained
independently to fit the same data will
likely agree when they are certain about
their predictions. And they will likely
disagree whenever there is uncertainty,
right? So, say you have N versions and
copies of the models that have been
trained independently.
If they will be probably agreeing close
to the regime of observed data, and they
will potentially disagree when we are
going far away from the from our data.
And so, ensembles basically
um
encapsulate this idea through an
algorithm,
which is basically saying
nothing else that we're saying here. In
ensembles, you would just train
independently N copies of your model and
and then average the prediction
according to these N models.
So, specifically what you would be doing
is we say we have five different um
neural network models which we train.
We could then get five different
predictions for our next state.
And so, what we can then do is maybe our
prediction would be the average
prediction across these models.
This could be one idea.
And maybe another way to visualize this
is
uh say that we have So, here the x-axis
represent the parameter space, theta.
Uh,
and the y-axis represents our basically
this is the posterior distribution over
parameters given data.
So, say that the ground truth posterior
distribution is represented by the
shaded uh kind of
uh multimodal distribution here.
The
and for now disregard uh VI which stands
for variational inference and this is
multi-SWAG algorithm. Uh
the ensembles would essentially mean in
this case
uh fitting four
different models, the blue ones,
independently.
Through uh optimization, these four
models will converge to four different
values of the parameters theta.
And so, this these parameters theta
might converge to different local minima
depending on how the optimization goes.
And so, these are essentially an
empirical approximation of the ground
truth uh posterior distribution. Because
they they will naturally, because of the
stochasticity of stochastic gradient
descent and uh the optimization process,
they will converge to different uh local
minima.
And so, these are a way of empirically
exploring the the landscape and
approximating the the ground truth uh
posterior distribution.
Yeah.
>> This is splitting the
the different modes. Yes.
Like cuz the goal
Here you have a multimodal distribution
of theta,
right?
Your goal is to figure out what all of
the modes are.
By having
this each one of these
You said neural networks like ensembles.
Each one of these represent
a different mode that you hopefully can
figure out in the structure.
>> Yeah, indeed. So, the idea here is that
this learning problem very likely has a
highly multimodal landscape of
solutions. Um
the approaches we are discussing before,
like Gaussian processes, try to derive
analytical expressions
for these exact distributions.
Ensembles here, on the other hand, uh
disregard any of these formal uh
approach and just decide to instantiate
n copies of these models,
maybe initialize them differently.
Uh
the stochasticity of gradient descent
still will lead them to converge to
different
uh different final solutions.
And by doing so, they will The hope is
that they will cover meaningful
different modes uh of the ground truth
posterior distribution.
So, I think your original question is
how do you differentiate between these
copies?
Uh
I would say if you're talking about
neural networks specifically, typically
these models are initialized randomly.
So, the initial values of the parameters
are are random.
And also, we're optimizing them to
stochastic gradient descent. And so, the
even the directions that they're
following will be uh random to some
extent. So, there is some natural
stochasticity that comes.
Yeah, no, indeed. So, uh this is
something that I I did not discuss. So,
the
idea is that formally So, I think
hopefully in practice it makes sense
what we're doing, right? So, we're
initializing four models, and then we
have four different um
converge parameters theta, and then we
could average over them.
What are we doing in practice is that we
are approximating the ground truth
posterior distribution
by taking the average of what is
referred to as as a direct distribution,
which is essentially saying that
say that I have one uh
observation of my theta. The Dirac
distribution is something that is
basically a spiky distribution that
gives all the probability mass exactly
to that point.
And so this is, if you wish, more
formally,
uh
how this process of averaging out
predictions from different models would
translate to the predictive posterior
that we were describing before.
Through the lens of these Dirac
distributions.
So remember that in the predictive
posterior, what we are saying is that we
want to average out over all the
different models that we're training.
Or specifically, average out over the
uh posterior distribution of our
parameters.
So do you do you remember the the
discussion we were doing on uh
predictive posterior and what that
means? How do we compute those
confidence bounds?
Is that we were basically
uh for each in the discrete case, for
each value of our parameters, we were
propagate basically predicting with that
value of the parameters. And then
waiting that probability uh that that
discrete that prediction with the
probability of how certain we were of
that specific value of the parameters.
In this case,
uh we are doing so not in the continuous
case, but through these uh kind of Dirac
approximations.
But does that make sense?
Okay. But so, long story
um
what we've been doing so far is that
we introduced this basic recipe for
um model-based reinforcement learning,
namely some version of uh
run a policy in the environment, collect
transitions,
fit the model to those transitions, and
then use that model for planning.
We motivated how uncertainty
or at least estimating uncertainty on
those predictions is likely very
important.
And now let's let's look at some
specific examples and how we could make
this work in practice.
So,
how can we make
use of this additional knowledge we just
we just gained?
Specifically, one mechanism to do so
could be the following. So, let's assume
that we have a candidate action sequence
again some
given to us by some planning algorithm.
And now we have
approximate model of the posterior
distribution of the parameters theta,
which we learned through, for example,
one of the methods we discussed today.
So, we could sample
a specific value of our parameters theta
from this posterior distribution.
And we could now propagate the learned
dynamics through
this specific instantiation of the
dynamical model.
We could then use the these this
propagated trajectory to compute our
predicted reward.
So, we're basically simulating in our
head what is happening. We are given a
candidate action sequence. We are
sampling one of the models from our
posterior distribution over models,
and we're using this to propagate
forward what is happening and scoring
the quality of what is happening.
And then we we can just repeat these
three steps
to basically compute the average reward
according to our
learned
posterior distribution.
Right? So,
specifically, we would be So, what this
algorithm is doing is directly
instantiating this idea that we were
describing pictorially over here.
Right? So, in the plot there, we were
saying that uncertainty gives us this
mechanism through which we can compute
the expected reward under our model.
And so, in this way, we could
basically approximate the expected
reward under all of our predicted
samples.
Does that make sense? Maybe, again, more
visually, what we're doing is that
we are given a candidate action
sequence.
We sample maybe one version of one
parameters from our posterior
distribution,
and we propagate the model forward.
Here,
we would be reaching a specific sum of
rewards over time
according to this specific model.
We could then sample a a different
version of the model, and we could have
a different propagated trajectory with a
different reward, right?
If we repeat this multiple times, we
would then have n of these propagated
futures.
And so, what we could do is that if we
average them out, we would then be
computing the an approximation of the
expected reward under the uncertainty of
our model.
Okay. So, of course,
um
one thing that I really want to make
sure that, you know, to convey is that
this is obviously just a choice, right?
So, we're not kind of the takeaway way
here, I think, should not be this is the
best way to go for when you're talking
about model based reinforcement learning
because ultimately it depends on the
problem at hand. Right? So maybe there
is even no need at all to look at
uncertainty quantification because just
having your
linear time invariant model is well
estimated enough and so there is no need
to do any of this. But in the general
case where
system dynamic approximation is
challenging and you want to use high
capacity models for approximating our
dynamics,
uncertainty plays a big role. And so
this could be one instantiation of this
idea of let's use whatever favorite way
to estimate posterior distribution over
parameters of our model and then use
this to meaningfully represent
expectation under this uncertainty.
And so just to to repeat myself, this is
only a choice
but it's one instantiation of this more
general idea that is whenever we want to
plan through a learned model,
we might want to be we might be
interested in evaluating the expected
reward under the learned model.
So
a particularly impactful paper
now a few years old but it uses exactly
these ideas
introduces algorithm called pets.
Whereby the main idea is that they were
using as a model basically an ensemble
of neural networks to approximate the
posterior over the model.
They were then
using
a sample basically different models from
this ensemble and use them to generate
predictions of different futures exactly
as we were saying in the previous slide.
And then they would be
uh,
this in a model predictive control
fashion. So, they they would basically
have a cross-entropy method to generate
these candidate plans
uh, through uh, these uh, exact same
algorithm which we just described. They
would basically take these candidate
plans and score them according to
samples from these ensemble of neural
networks
and then pick the best action based on
that
and implement this in a receding horizon
fashion. So, you predict a full plan,
uh, you you actuate only the first step
in the plan and you repeat this process.
And so, this is just a quick note, but
it's something that I think it's this is
a nice paper if you if you want to read
about these these models in practice.
Okay, but does it make sense how this is
like one instantiation of what what
we're saying?
Okay.
So, in in this paper specifically, uh,
and I'm using this as an example to
highlight the classical benefits of
model-based RL
um, is that here they would be measuring
performance of, well, their method in
blue,
uh, compared to, well, a bunch of
different baselines. But, for example,
they're comparing against, uh, PPO or
soft actor critic, which is a also a
version of the actor critic methods we
discussed in class.
Uh,
across a number of different tasks. Uh,
and I would say the most interesting
result here is that these model-based
methods, namely the blue curves,
generally are much more sample
efficient. So, if we compare the
performance on the Y axis in general
with respect to the number of time steps
in through which they had to interact
with the environment, you could see that
maybe the performance at convergence is
fairly similar.
Uh, but the blue curves typically tend
to converge to this
you know, converge performance much
faster.
And this is because through
learning the model itself, you we can
basically circumvent a lot of the
interactions with the with the
environment.
So generally, the benefits in
model-based RL
uh
often relate with uh sample efficiency.
Okay. So any any questions before
wrapping up the the class?
Yeah.
>> What's your favorite method?
>> So
I like to be fairly uh
you know, agnostic and pragmatic uh
depending on the on the problem at hand.
I would say that
>> [snorts]
[laughter]
>> No, you're saying this is the diplomatic
answer, yeah. No, I would say that the
model-free algorithms are definitely
more mature as a technology. And so I
would say algorithms such as PPO and
soft actor-critic are typically the way
to go for a continuous control.
Uh
model-based RL still very active line of
research. So
if I have to pick one, I would go for
soft actor-critic or PPO. Yeah. Well,
those are two, but
>> [laughter]
>> those two. Yeah.
Uh
yeah, so I think this is a nice leeway
into a kind of basically what I wanted
to discuss here. Because throughout this
class, we have been introducing, you
know, n different ways of
behaving when looking at optimal
control, right? So ranging from
open-loop methods, it could be indirect
and direct, closed-loop, dynamic
programming, reinforcement learning,
imitation learning. And so the question
that you could ask is, I mean, this is
great, but you're just confusing me. Now
I have to pick among hundreds of these
algorithms. How do I navigate this? And
the the point here is that
these methods are not in competition
with each other, but they're actually
well, different methods will be tailored
to different applications. And actually
most of the time is these methods are
combined with each other. And this is
because the
decision-making
pipeline is typically organized as a
through a hierarchical structure.
Specifically, if we were to decompose
this hierarchical structure,
generally we would start with having a
model of the world or a representation
of what is interesting for us.
For example, take the case of
autonomous driving.
We might have some maybe semantic maps
of what we're observing in our
environment.
And given whatever representation of the
world we are interested in, we would
then have kind of the the autonomy stack
is typically decomposed through
different modules that interact with
each other. So the first kind of
decision that you have to make is
typically some higher-level goal for our
system, right? So we are perceiving the
world and now we have to choose what we
want to perform.
Specifically, these high-level decisions
might be kind of continuing the
autonomous driving example, something
along the lines of picking if I want to
change a lane or not. So these are very
high-level
actions and decisions that we want to
make. At this level of the hierarchy,
this is typically where methods that
belong to kind of closed-loop dynamic
programming-like algorithms lie. And
this is because for these higher-level
decision-making
aspects, you we typically want to encode
stochasticity and want to make sure that
we are dealing with the stochasticity
when picking decisions.
And the output of this
uh is typically in a form of a goal, for
example, lane change.
Now we have this goal, but we have to
make it actionable, right? So, we want
to make this such that we have an actual
uh you know, trajectory which we can
enact in the in the world.
And so, this is something that usually
uh is dealt with open-loop techniques.
So, we would have this higher-level
goal, like a navigation goal, and then
we want to translate this navigation
goal into a finer-grain trajectory which
we want our car to follow.
This trajectory obviously encodes some
notion of the dynamics of the vehicle.
Despite this might be maybe some
uh lower-fidelity models of the
dynamics, but still we want to enclose
encode some constraints in terms of
safety, some constraints in terms of
dynamics. And so, this is where uh
open-loop techniques typically
uh fall.
Once we have a trajectory, we want to
uh make sure this is
uh
you know, physically tractable and
implemented in the on the hardware,
right? So,
this is where
usually ideas from model predictive
control, specifically in its tracking
instantiations, uh common place.
So, we would have a reference trajectory
that is given from the open-loop uh
algorithm.
And now we want to make sure, first of
all, that we're tracking this over time,
but also potentially including a
finer-grained uh
dynamical models of our of the system,
maybe some uh
safety-oriented constraints which we
were avoiding in the open-loop uh stage.
Um and so forth. So, we start from
representation of the world.
We use uh higher-level decision-making
to have a high-level goal for our
system.
We compute a trajectory that tries to
achieve that goal. We then want to
implement this trajectory in practice,
so we want to make sure we are tracking
it.
And obviously, last but not least, we
feed
these to the actuators, right? So, at
the end of the day, we have to
make this work on the real-world
hardware. And so, we want to make sure
that this is actually tracked by what is
happening in reality. And so, this is
usually where things like PID controls
come into place.
Of course, throughout all of this, we
might have some
safety concerns, and we could be dealing
with safety-critical applications.
For example, in the case of driving, we
might have some
set of states which we do not want to
visit because of some safety concepts
which we care about. And so, the safety
concepts
which are which may be a computed
through things such as Hamilton-Jacobi
reachability,
are typically mechanisms through which
we can inform both
or either or either of open-loop and the
tracking
module.
So,
in a way, I hope this is starting to
make a little bit more concrete what I
mean when I say that these techniques
which we introduced in this class are
definitely not exclusive, but actually
typically combine in a autonomy stack.
And the details of these algorithms will
obviously depend on the application. But
so, we hope that with the with this
class, we give you first of all a broad
understanding of all of these concepts,
and also
focused on the
kind of higher-level understanding of
how these modules could be combined, and
the pros and cons of of these ideas.
All of this is obviously
in
kind of we should, I think, concretize
this in a moment in time where
learning-based and end-to-end approaches
are definitely becoming more and more
popular.
And so, I would say that historically,
learning has started from the higher
levels of this abstraction. So,
perception is the first
kind of situation where learning
basically became the the factor
standard.
And I would say that right now,
kind of end-to-end approaches are
more or less starting to carve its way
their way down along this hierarchy. I
would say right now, they're basically
somewhere over here. So, in between the
open-loop and the kind of closed-loop
trajectory tracking stage.
I would say even the most bullish, you
know, companies or approaches that
claim, you know, end-to-end approaches,
typically they don't mess with the lower
level
components.
And this is because here is really where
you want to make sure you have
fine-grain control, you're encoding hard
constraint guarantees,
and making sure that everything works
concretely in practice.
Okay. So, if there are no further
questions, I want to really thank you
very much for sticking with us
throughout this this quarter
and wishing you best of luck for the for
your exam.
>> [applause]